[Musique]
nous sommes le jeudi 24 novembre 2016
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 et les inviter celles et ceux qui
font l'actualité dans le département
voici le sommaire jean frédéric poisson
candidat à la primaire de la droite
président du parti chrétien démocrate a
apporté son soutien pour le second tour
à françois fillon mais au-delà de cette
élection quel sera l'avenir politique de
celui qui est également député de la 2e
circonscription il est en plateau pour
en parler moi sans tabac l'opération
lancée par le ministère de la santé
touche à sa fin mais l'opération est
elle véritablement efficace le point de
vue du docteur christine camus car trop
tabacologue ce sera dans quelques
minutes
jean frédéric poisson bonsoir bonsoir et
bienvenue sur ce plateau mérite à peu
près 18h30 un lorsque nous enregistrons
cette séquence dans moins de deux heures
il y aura le débat l'ultime débat de
cette campagne de la primaire de la
droite et du centre
j'imagine que vous avez le suivre ce
débat bien sûr avec attention
vous vous attendez à un débat difficile
entre alain juppé et françois fillon le
ton a été rude dans l'auto dans les rues
de pendant les trois premiers jours de
la deûle entre deux tours mais j'ai
entendu un certain nombre de portes
paroles d'alain juppé a souhaité que les
politiques cessent et que l'on revienne
à une forme de calme qui devrait
présider en général aux échanges
politiques ce qui augure d'un débat
certes sans doute musclé certainement
très différenciée puisqu'on voit bien
qu'il y a deux trajectoires possibles
pour le pays
mon souhait c'est qu'on voie clairement
ces deux trajectoires et que les
électeurs puissent choisir en pleine
connaissance de cause
notre choix s'est d'ores et déjà porté
vers françois fillon il va revenir un
petit peu sur les motivations pourquoi
l'avoir rejoint qu'est ce qui a
déclenché justement cette volonté chez
vous de le soutenir sachant qu'il ya des
points de différence on va y revenir à
venir sur wii le fait que sur un certain
nombre de sujets que je nous considérons
comme essentiel et sur lesquels je les
sollicite et c'est à dire la question de
la famille la question de l'éducation la
question du service national la lutte
contre la pauvreté il partage des
richesses et enfin la question du
dialogue social sur ces cinq éléments
qui ont été pour nous pendre et campagne
primaire des éléments centraux françois
fillon a manifesté un un souhait de les
voir effectivement occupé une place de
premier plan dans son propre projet
c'est la base d'un accord politique et
j'espère d'un travail commun qui se
poursuivra dans la suite je parlais des
points de désaccord il ya quelques
instants
maintenir le principe des mariages pour
tous le programme économique qui est
beaucoup plus libéral aussi oui ça se
sont pas de point rédhibitoire pendant
non parce que d'abord il y aura sans
doute des ajustements possibles et je
pense qu'il en faudra parce que comment
dire le jeu reste très interrogatif sur
la possibilité pour notre pays et pour
les français de supporter une austérité
qui me paraît décalée par rapport à ce
qu'on peut effectivement être capable
d'accueillir dans la situation du pays
aujourd'hui
maintenant
ce qui rassemble de projet permet je
crois malgré tout envisager une
coopération fructueuse
lorsque vous dites ça veut dire que le
projet qui est présenté aujourd'hui par
françois fillon n'est pas le projet
définitif finalement up de toute façon
vous savez un projet politique ça a
évolué avec le temps
les électeurs de se prononcer ce
week-end bien sûr que oui mais ils se
produisent près ils se présenteront ils
se prononceront par an sur la base de ce
qui leur est présenté je ne doute pas de
la sincérité de françois fillon dans ce
qu'il présente maintenant la campagne
présidentielle va s'ouvrir
la situation de la france sera dans six
mois tel que nous ne la connaissons pas
et absolument pas aujourd'hui est donc
une campagne faite aussi bouger un
certain nombre de lignes et d'éléments
donc il faut s'attendre à quelques
évolutions je pense sur un certain
nombre de sujets ce qui serait légitime
et par ailleurs sa manifesterait une
volonté d'écouté et de prise en compte
de la part de françois fillon d'un
certain nombre de personnes qui l'ont
rejoint qui vont de rejoindre en cours
dans l'avenir et ça permettrait de
rassembler cette famille cette grande
famille de la droite parce
qu'aujourd'hui très clairement on le
voit il ya quand même même si le
programme en ligne de fond et commun
forcément et encore heureux au sein
d'une formation politique mais a quand
même deux visions qui s'opposent imagine
mal éventuellement alain juppé ensuite
soutenir pleinement par exemple il ya
des visions qui s'opposent vous avez
raison mais comme vous le dit très
justement il ya malgré tout un certain
nombre de points communs qui justifie le
fait que nous soyons dans la même
famille sur la vision de la société sano
brahim m nous sommes tous convaincus de
l'intérêt de la responsabilité
individuelle de la nécessité de
renforcer la puissance de l'état de
relancer l'économie de faire en sorte
que les choses seraient plus fluide en
france en règle générale tout ça ce sont
les points communs qui malgré tout
permettre d'imaginer un rassemblement
ensuite ça ne sont pas que sur des
nuances que
les programmes diffèrent bien entendu ça
la question
vraie question de société dispose
évidemment cela étant dit il me semble
que le rassemblement est nécessaire de
toute manière je reviens à battre au
score sur ce premier tour de la primaire
1,5 pour cent près de 70 mille voix
c'est insatisfaisant par rapport à vos
objectifs salmon que en dehors des trois
ténors on va les qualifier comme ça
l'ensemble des autres candidats se sont
basés les mois qui arrivent à se
partager un peu les miettes en réalité
deux observations la première c'est que
les français se sont portés massivement
après un peu plus de 93 % sur les trois
candidats qu'ils pouvaient faire état
d'une expérience réelle à la tête et à
la conduite de l'état dans le passé ce
qui indique qu' ils sont pas prêts pour
entre guillemets laventure ou des choses
un peu nouvelle ou un peu innovante et
ça c'est paradoxal parce qu'en général
quand il ya des sondages et quand on les
sollicite les français sont plutôt
partisan du renouveau changer les
visages des politiques mais je pense que
oui mais c'est ça fait partie des
paradoxes sur le regard que portent les
français sur le gars politique ça
dépanne seul mais je crois qu'il ya
surtout l'expression d'une forme
d'inquiétude très clairement je pense
que les français savent sentent très
bien tout seul dans une situation
extrêmement difficile très graves et que
comme dit l'autre quand on est par gros
temps il vaut mieux être à la barre du
bateau quelqu'un qui a l'expérience de
navigation
deuxièmement sur bons scores en
particulier le score à surpoids rythme
éthique est évidemment décevant j'aurais
préféré qu'il soit supérieur
j'ai compris que je n'étais pas tout à
fait seul dans ce cas par ailleurs il
est certain que ma présence dans la
campagne a considérablement influé à sa
tombe de tels qu'ils ont été discutés y
compris d'ailleurs l'orientation du
projet de françois fillon sur la fin de
la campagne primaire dans le dernier
mois et tout le monde est parfaitement
conscient du fait que le poids que nous
avons pesé avec le parti chrétien
démocrate dans la campagne est
sensiblement supérieur au score qui
arithmétiquement demeure l'objectivation
de la voix des électeurs mais par
rapport à ce résultat on vous a aussi
entendu très critique
on va dire ça comme ça vis-à-vis de
votre traitement dans les médias par
exemple oui vous le déplorez bien sûr et
on peut y revenir il ya eu ce coup des
coups d'éclat médiatiques sur plateau de
fruits libre exemple il y en a un autre
lorsque le journal
au jour d'aujourd'hui on aujourd'hui en
france le parisien samedi matin met à la
une de son journal six candidats et non
pas 7 pour annoncer le premier tour de
la primaire
il ya là quelque chose qui surprend
déontologique est insupportable je
reconnais tout à fait droit à la
rédaction du parisien de ne pas partager
la vision de la france
il a aussi le droit de ne pas mettre les
sept candidats en photos de nos maîtres
que si ce n'est pas moi mais c'est pas
un prof de droit sa preuve d'éthique et
dans la conception de la vie politique
et de la formation qui est la mienne
de telles choses ne devraient pas se
passer c'est à jouer dans les résultats
ça a sans doute joué un peu mais très
franchement le mouvement de fond qui a
emporté les quatre candidats réputés
plus petits dans le scrutin de dimanche
dernier est d une telle ampleur que
comment dire ça n'aurait corriger les
choses malgré tout cas la marge mais
encore une fois c'est pas prime de ce
corps c'est un prime de comportement et
d'appréhension et de combat et de
comment dire d'éthique journalistique
tout simplement c'est ça que j'ai quand
vous lui contester et sur plateau de
france 3 et que je conteste en ce moment
en ce qui concerne la le comportement de
la rédaction d'aujourd'hui en france le
parisien
dans cette édition de samedi dernier vos
objectifs
à présent je le rappelais total et en
introduction vous êtes la députée de la
10e circonscription des yvelines avant
tout et vous si léger encore aujourd'hui
oui oui de même en plus d'être président
du parti chrétien démocrate
quels sont vos objectifs cède ça va être
de vous engager à dans la précampagne de
cette primaire aux avions ont été
entendus nous sommes rencontrés et
françois fillon lundi dernier nous avons
remis à plus tard les échanges sur cet
aspect laissons passer d'abord le second
tour de la primaire
je respecte assez à la fois les
institutions le choix des électeurs et
les candidats en campagne pour ne pas
perturbée ce qui est la préparation
normale et l'échéance de dimanche
prochain faut d'abord que françois
fillon gagne dimanche prochain puis
après on pourra parler de la suite j'ai
confiance mais mais si on fait de la
politique fiction françois fillon
l'ambiance prochain l'emportant 2010 en
nous un ministère de la famille par
exemple nous discuterons luiz qui trompe
tout ça le moment venu ce n'est pas du
tout dans les objectifs je ne lui ai pas
demandé me l'a pas proposé et nous
n'avons pas parlé de ça je suis comme
aujourd'hui tendue vers mon seul
objectif c'est à dire celui de redevenir
député de la 10e circonscription des
yvelines et je serai candidat à ma
propre succession j'annoncerai ça
évidemment le moment venu ça n'est pas
encore venu mais ma seule ambition c'est
de continuer à défendre les intérêts de
mon pays et des français à l'assemblée
nationale à partir du match l'an
prochain sauf si on vous propose un
poste et des ministres en traitant coûté
pour l'instant encore une fois ça n'est
pas à l'ordre du jour ça n'a pas été
fait et je n'ai pas demandé parce que
vous insistez 1 sur ce poste de ministre
de la famille qui est quand même
particulièrement stratégie si mais si on
ne vous propose pas parce que vous
souhaiter qu'il soit placé au dessus du
ministère de l'environnement par exemple
oui pourra varier pour rappeler la
priorité de la préoccupation sur les
personnes humaines ou à l'égard des
personnes humaines par rapport aux
préoccupations sur leur environnement je
crois qu'il ya là un ordre des choses
qui me paraît mieux organisés et mieux
établie lorsque l'on manifeste davantage
d'importance aux familles qu'à
l'environnement dans lequel vivent les
familles ce qui n'est pas une marque de
dédain à l'égard d'environnement pas du
tout est au contraire comme élu local à
la tête de la communauté d'agglomération
de rambouillet territoire de londres ont
tous les jours néanmoins dans les
politiques publiques
je crois qu'il ya sept cet ordre à
mettre en place par ailleurs encore une
fois sur l'architecturé prochaine du
gouvernement les choses viendront en
leur temps si elles viennent ce n'est
pas à l'ordre du jour pour le moment
dernière question très rapidement vous
n'avez pas de regret de ne pas vous est
présentée directement à cette
présidentielle est de passer par la case
de la primaire non parce que j'ai
toujours considéré ou en tout cas au
moment où nous avons pris la décision où
j'ai plus tard dans ma décision je
considérais que la présidentielle se
jouerait au couteau entre les trois
grandes formations politiques qui
peuvent aspirer à être présente au
second tour le front national de parti
socialiste est bien sûr et avant tout le
candidat de la droite et du centre
et je ne voulais pas et
parti chrétien démocrate n'a pas voulu
prendre le risque de priver le candidat
de la droite et du centre des quelques
points
il y aurait éventuellement manquer pour
accéder au second tour donc c'est une
décision que nous avons prise en
responsabilité je ne regrette absolument
pas d'avoir plus merci jean frédéric
poisson
en tout cas vous l'avait annoncé
prochainement candidat dans cette
circonscription à la 10eme sauf si bien
évidemment un poste de ministre se
propose anthonin didier loquet la
deuxième qui est la plus belle
circonscription du département c'est
pour ça qu'elle est chère à mon coeur
merci jean frédéric poisson est devenu
un plateau le mois sans être tabac
arrive bientôt à son terme cette
initiative portée par le ministère de la
santé consiste à encourager les fumeurs
à stopper la cigarette durant tout un
mois justement cela permettrait de
multiplier par cinq les chances
d'arrêter définitivement alors est ce
vraiment efficace
nous sommes allés poser la question un
tabacologue du centre hospitalier elles
deux vers ça et c'est au micro de
nicolas kirilow vite on avait déjà la
journée mondiale sans tabac mais qu'ils
étaient tous les 31 mai mais
effectivement qui ne durait qu'une
journée donc c'est la première année
qu'il ya un mois complet sans tabac ça
permet à un certain nombre de patients
sans qu'ils soient stigmatisés parce
qu'on parle pas des fumeurs on parle du
sans tabac donc de prendre conscience
qu'on peut peut-être essayer de s'en
passer plus qu'une chose qu'une journée
voire à moi
d'autant plus que cette méthode a été
accompagné à partir du 1er novembre
d'une augmentation du remboursement
forfaitaire qui était essentiellement de
50 euros sauf quelques cas particuliers
et qui est maintenant 250 euros pour
tous les fumeurs qui souhaitent prendre
des substituts nicotiniques pour arrêter
de fumer ou qui en ont besoin parce que
c'est pas forcément souhaitée on n'a pas
toujours besoin
certains patients souhaitent vraiment
arrêter du jour au lendemain
d'autres préfèrent y aller
progressivement néanmoins ce mois sans
tabac peut être pris comme on commence à
réduire le but étant un jour d'arrivée à
ne plus fumer
sachant qu'une fois qu'on aura atteint
cette étape
le problème aussi va perdre
et puisqu'il va falloir aussi apprendre
à ne pas recommencer à fumer c'est à
dire ne pas rechuter
et ça c'est aussi très compliqué le
problème c'est que la dépendance au
tabac qu'ils dépendance complexe elle
est due à trois choses une dépendance
physique donc avec des besoins
essentiellement nicotine une dépendance
psychologique donc avec un certain
nombre d'émotions qui sont liées au
tabagisme est une dépendance
comportementale avec un certain nombre
de réflexes conditionnés d'habitude prix
autour du tabac quand on arrête de fumer
on est pris en charge dont par des
médicaments ou des substituts
nicotiniques pour la dépendance physique
la dépendance psychologique et la
dépendance comportementale nécessite un
suivi un accompagnement par des
professionnels de santé formés à la
tabacologie
et quand il ya des rechutes elle est
essentiellement due à la dépendance
psychologique c'est à dire que la
dépendance physique et a disparu
la dépendance comportementale aussi est
il ya une émotion qui va revenir et qui
va faire rechuter
donc cette dépendance psychologique
nécessite un suivi au long cours pour
apprendre à gérer les émotions sans la
cigarette
or l'apprentissage nécessite de la
répétition et du temps personne
n'apprend instantanément à faire quelque
chose sachant que pour le tabac
il ya derrière des années de tabagisme
et que c'est pas au bout de quelques
jours d'arrêt où au bout d'un mois qu'on
a appris à ne plus avoir besoin de la
cigarette on parle d' arrêt récent du
tabac quand ça fait six mois qu'on ne
fume plus tard et qui durent persistant
bout d'un an et d'arrêt confirmé au bout
de deux ans ça veut dire qu'au bout de
deux ans ça veut pas dire qu'on ne
refusera jamais millions beaucoup moins
de rechute en dans les deux ans qui
suivent la règle
au delà donc le ser qu'il ya
essentiellement la majorité des rechutes
surviennent au bout de six mois il y en
a un peu moins après et après deux ans
il ya quand même quelques rechutes mais
beaucoup moins donc en fait l'arrêt du
tabac nécessiteraient un suivi dans ses
deux ans fin du set 8 invités pour ce
soir rendez vous lundi dès 18h et 45
pour une nouvelle édition de la
rédaction d'ici là n'oubliez pas les
replays sur notre site internet très
belle soirée
[Musique]